un golpe legal a las esperanzas del
partido Nacional escocés de celebrar
otro referéndum la Independencia el
próximo octubre el tribunal supremo del
Reino Unido adictaminado por unanimidad
que la Facultad de convocar un
referéndum está reservada al parlamento
británico la primera ministra escocesa a
Nicolás Target dijo que respetaba la
sentencia del tribunal pero considera
que roja duda sobre la democracia dentro
del referéndum de la devolución de
Escocia en el que hay una especie de
descentralización del poder de Londres
sobre edimburgo en cuanto a gasto social
o recaudación de impuestos tal vez lo
que la sentencia de hoy confirma más que
nada Es que la única garantía de
igualdad para Escocia dentro de la
familia británica de Naciones es la
independencia debemos encontrar y
encontraremos otro medio democrático
legal y constitucional para que el
pueblo escuches exprese su voluntad
dijo que convertiría las próximas
elecciones generales en una votación de
sobre la separación del resto de Reino
Unido haciendo campaña únicamente sobre
esa premisa Mientras tanto el Primer
Ministro de Richard sunak dio la
bienvenida al fallo creo que el pueblo
de Escocia quiere que trabajemos para
solucionar los principales retos a los
que nos enfrentamos colectivamente ya
sea la economía el apoyo al sistema de
salud o el apoyo a Ucrania ahora es el
momento de que los políticos trabajan
juntos
ha rechazado repetidamente que Escocia
celebre otro referéndum dice que el de
2014 en el que el 55% de los escoceses
rechazó la independencia sanjó la
cuestión durante una generación pero el
Partido Nacional escocés Dice que ahora
hay un mandato indiscutible debido a una
mayoría que apoya la independencia en el
parlamento Escocia se vio obligada a
abandonar la Unión Europea junto al
resto de Reino Unido Pese a que la
mayoría de los escoceses votaron en
contra del brexit